I hope you're all doing fine better than
me okay today we've got a busy day we're
gonna be talking about the rational
scientific method and if you've never
heard of it well you're you're in for a
big shock here okay and just so I don't
waste your time if you're a newbie here
I'll go very briefly through something a
little introduction so that I scare you
out of here as quickly as possible don't
waste your time okay in science we do
not do experiments in science we do not
observe anything we do not gawk in
science we do not use math we do not use
equations we do not use numbers okay and
in science we do not make predictions so
anyone who does any of those things is
doing religion okay we have a new
scientific method we have a new version
of science since the beginning of this
century 21st century and that's what we
pass on to the new generations okay so
if you do any of those experiment you
bring the word observation observe in
any way shape or form you're going to be
offended in the sight okay if you do
predictions and if you do math you're in
the wrong sight okay help you do science
we do not do religion that's what we're
gonna talk about today okay but first of
all let's start with some of the fan
mail that I got and I got quite a bit
this I hope I can go through it all okay
let's go over the first one good comment
by a fellow he says came for [ __ ] on
Sega and thirty minutes in and all we've
talked about are retards and gay Rams
yeah you're right
I'm so sorry sometimes it takes long
because I get a lot of questions
comments and I try to address them okay
and I think it does educate the public
I answer those questions all I can tell
you is I'm gonna try from now on to put
the timestamps I put the timestamps on
the second one so so if you happen to go
back there you'll see the timestamp when
say the the section on Sagan starts okay
so yeah I'm gonna be putting the
timestamps because I I hear you okay I
know you're right I'm so sorry another
fella around the something similar said
now you you're on Sagan all right a
little behind the curve but forgivable
why don't you get the Cavendish
michelson-morley Gale Aries stop going
after stupid celebrities we are way past
that yeah you're right okay also all I
can tell you is a lot of people don't
know who michelson-morley are they don't
know who area is you know and I've
covered a lot of these guys in the past
okay so if you go through some of the
videos you'll find me talking about a
lot of these fellows
okay I've talked about eletricity I've
talked about magnetism and I've included
all these fellas in there to one degree
or another but right now you know I'm
looking at these celebrities because
that's what the names people hear out
there people don't know about
arrey or you know or who Cavendish was a
lot of people don't know those people
those folks right those historical
figures but you mentioned carl sagan you
mention tyson you mentioned bill nye
brian greene a lot of people have heard
about it why because they're the names
kicked around today so those are the
names that need to be addressed because
they're the people spreading the
religion of mathematical physics these
days they're the ones who are
perpetuating the nonsense of quantum
mechanics and relativity and straight
theory words okay so I'm gonna be
addressing the celebrities of today and
I might make reference to the people in
the past okay okay let's go on with a
first real comment here and we have the
sky he says most of your initial weight
loss is water weight yeah I'm well aware
that I'm trying to lose weight
and I had some back problem but about
two weeks ago and it scared the hell out
of me because they're really painful and
so I went on a crash diet went from 96
kilograms to where I'm at now 89 and I'm
gonna stabilize a little bit there then
drop a little more and I've done this in
the past already I went down all the way
to 85 one hair all back just like the
guys saying here once you start eating
properly again these will be replaced
and the weight once lost will return
yeah I'm well aware of that
I'm well aware of that and the reason it
came back is that it pay attention I
didn't weigh myself I just ate and yeah
I'm not supposed to do that at my age
I've got on 68 this year and part of is
the belly the beer belly I've got
pulling on my spine and I think that's
part of the problem the muscles are
giving way and the other one is that you
weigh on your knees and I don't need all
that weight of my age so the first order
of the day was to reduce weight you know
and then I'll figure out about you know
not losing muscle and the other stuff
that you talked about here and yeah I
agree with you you you lose muscle you
lose different things that you're not
supposed to but right now the number one
issue for me was you know get rid of the
weight because it's uh you don't want to
weigh that much not at my age you don't
need it that weight okay more related to
to that issue which I love the Lord you
know one of these guys say it says don't
eat fruit you know the cause of cancer
is are insects
yeah I do get these comments I want you
to know so what does another fellow say
well he says uh lots of mono fruits
meals alone an inversion table does
every any animal tissues again man is a
book all these doctors you know that I
they come and visit me you know I don't
know which one to you know get a second
opinion the second opinions 180 degrees
from the first one so I don't know what
to do anymore
one says eat fruit don't eat animal the
other ones eat animals don't eat roots
okay okay here's another one says raw
primal best grass-fed quality I know
that you'll be healthier if I eat just
lead me you know no fad no anything okay
so I don't know what to do anymore
anybody have more six more suggestions
I like this other one this one was my
favorite okay it says I have I love food
and do not like to do the deprivation of
diets
I would rather fast and then enjoy
whatever I like 100% in accordance
that's what I do
whatever I like I don't worry about you
know all these little things that people
have on their heads these days I mean
everybody's an expert today forget it
you know everybody has gone onto the
internet they did a complete search of
every ailment they can think of they
know exactly how everybody's a doctor
okay everybody's a doctor today and so
they one guy says don't eat mean eat
fruits the other guy says no eat me
don't eat prunes don't even there let me
tell you what my quickly what my vision
on that is what my way of thinking is on
that all the way to the beginning of our
species let's let's give a date just
arbitrary two hundred thousand years ago
we were hunter-gatherers we ate meat 24
hours a day every day of the week I know
this hurts the vegetarians of vegans and
all these people we ate meat we killed
animals we didn't use the Spears to hunt
lettuce okay and that's hard for some of
these people to understand we killed
animals okay so did the Nando's they one
study says that they looked at their
bones and they said that these people
these Neanderthals 98 plus percent of
their diet was meat and I think that's
true I think
all these hominids hominins whatever you
know they they they hunted meat and they
killed animals and that's how we got
here if if we have this long history we
would think that we are meat eaters
primarily now they'd be scavenged yeah
but what do we scavenge we scavenge
something that the lion killed maybe or
whatever right and only when we came to
the Neolithic that we start or a little
before that right bu we started
discovering that you could eat grains
you know and then from there on we we
invented subsistence farming first and
in commercial farming next okay so
veggies we're never in our diet until
very recently in human history if we're
gonna again we're gonna put the
beginning of man 200,000 years ago we
are not veggie vegetarians you know we
are omnivores we eat both but we have a
long history of meat and I think our
bodies are more or less designed to eat
meat and yeah while you're at it why not
eat veggies I mean I like fruits I like
veggies too I'm not gonna give up me the
fact my favorite ones are pigs love pigs
okay and so if I were a lion I'd be
eating well pigs okay here's another
comment as we were talking about autism
the other day and the fact that I'm
saying that it was genetically related
why is it you didn't mention vaccination
for a cause of autism I got several of
those here's another one none got excess
let's put it up here so this is it at
the case that many parents reported that
after multiple vaccinations their
children went suddenly went became
autistic and another one yet the last
one here immunization of our children
vaccines you don't mention it why and
then says and how can you compare the
cases of Down syndrome which is clearly
a genetic disorder well I think there's
a where your theory backfires okay yeah
when we see something all
yes obvious obvious you see someone with
Down syndrome you say that guy was born
that way his mother didn't educate him
to be like that and so we all accept
that Coen syndrome I discussed that the
other day uh it's causing all kinds of
havoc among the Amish you know and were
they educated to be like that obviously
not everybody looks at them says this
guy was born that way
period we're done so nobody has a
problem with that but when you come into
autism and homosexuality oh man now you
got a big fight on your hand they said
no he was educated that way or or
something he ate or maybe it was what
was he guys said the other day the fact
that we're using phones and maybe the
electromagnetic waves going through his
head who knows what I'm saying that all
these are genetically related why
because we have again assuming we've
been around for 200,000 years and
probably more our forefathers you know
whatever our species then we've been
inbreeding since that time we've been in
breeding we never interbred with
Neanderthals like the loonies at the Max
Planck Institute's proposed the
geneticist well that's absolute nonsense
and you know I've got a lot of videos on
that but no we never interbred with any
other species we have since then and
we've been inbreeding and after two
hundred three hundred thousand years of
inbreeding guess what you get what the
Amish have found out in the last 300
years you know they came with 1500
families today there are 325 thousand
Amish and they're having a lot of
genetic not only physical problems but
mental problems among them out is well
they say they don't have autism but they
have some some worse things like Cohen
syndrome and they have homosexuality as
well and so why are you gonna say why
are you gonna say those are not
genetically related is it because it's
not so obvious as Down syndrome is that
the reason yeah you gotta consider the
fact that we've been inbreeding for
a long time and inbreeding leads to all
kinds of physical and mental and mental
ailments diseases what do you want to
call it okay
so yeah there is there is uh you got to
take that into consideration
you cannot leave genetics out of it
because we have been inbreeding and that
is I think the number one factor now
other are the agricultural corporations
poisoning us yeah okay is there a lot of
pressure from society the fact that we
have the internet social distance and a
lot of things that are going on in our
environment maybe the air we breathe
what is it
climate change I don't know what else to
think about yeah all those might have an
effect I talked about Calhoun's
experiments density ok density might
have an effect okay will we live in mega
cities 20 million people you never used
to be the case in the past okay so all
these things might have an effect I'm
saying the primary ingredient genetics
we've been inbreeding anyone you marry
today is either your brother or your
sister from a genetic point of view okay
okay
moving on here along the same lines I
think it's the last comment on on this
issue and again says most human genetic
variation is found within populations
not between them yeah absolutely true
but absolutely irrelevant to the point
that I made just want to make sure that
here are the some of the papers you know
there's more papers on this issue and
you can look at that first one
similarities within and between human
populations and the other one genetic
structure of human populations and they
argue essentially that yeah the same
that's where that statement comes from
okay but then the point that I was
trying to make is what these other
people are saying here and this has been
with other studies as well and I'll just
read that last statement theirs has
found that a Western chimpanzee has more
differences genetically from an Eastern
chimp than any one human being has from
another here we have a few animals
they're known as chimps also occurs
within the bonobos and they are smaller
chimp essentially and they have more
diversity not only within but also
between populations than all of the
human race and we are eight billion
people and they are a few thousand so
you can't rule out genetics and people
rule out genetics like oh because
they're bombarded with all this
information today about doctors doing
their research and so on
that's all they pay attention to oh the
food I eat oh yeah that's gotta be it
you know they're poisoning me so
everybody carries their bottle of water
around you know I never never drink
water you'll never see me drinking water
maybe maybe you drink a pill or
something like that I drink beer and
wine what would you want to drink water
I mean it says there a desert out there
we walk through the desert I don't
understand that everybody with a water
bomb and if I drink water I'll drink it
from the sink I'll never drink by a
bottle of water you crazy if I'm going
to a Shell station or whatever I'm gonna
buy a beer and drink it while I'm
driving that's what I do don't drink and
drive you know but I do anyways I'll be
put in prison one of these days again
okay let's start with more physical
related comments okay
there is info on light rays path and he
points to this website so I go to this
website to find out what it's about and
this law says the experiments at Sprint
corporation where we were right which
can now be easily replicated proved I
like that word proved as soon as I hear
the word proved I know I'm talking to
what a person who believes in the old
scientific method the one that died in
the 20th century every time someone uses
the word proof experiments right we know
there
nuts in the head these people brainwash
hypnotized they have not come out of
there you know they can't think outside
the box
prove conclusively conclusively okay
that light is a wave well how could they
prove conclusively really that light is
a wave when there is no physical object
called a wave
it's like saying they prove that light
is a spirit oh yeah okay you know how do
you prove that light is a spirit how do
you prove that light is a wave when
there's no physical entity standalone
entity called a wave wave is a concept
worse it's a dynamic concept so it can't
it doesn't qualify as an object for the
purposes of physics so there's a video
video a video that I have called a wave
theory for idiots please watch it so you
never use the word wave again to make
your point you can't say that light is a
wave okay well okay that caught my eye
and says of course if light is a way
which an ain't okay there must be a
medium for light to vibrate well there
we agree there's got to be a medium
right that medium is ether oh my god so
what is the ether okay substance which
fills the universe what is he talking
about well we discussed that in the past
what is the ether well here's the waving
of the ether this is light okay so get
ready with your camera's okay filming
there he goes that's what the ether is a
bunch of particles that's what it is
bunch of particles and those particles
are supposedly waving and that waving
they call light and it's not only the
ether folk of the 19th century and their
descendants today it's everyone it's the
quantum mechanics believes in the ether
general relativity believes in the ether
quantum mechanics calls it the virtual
particles or maybe the direct sea or
some idiotic name like that
they believe in the same thing they
believe the space is made out of
particles and I'll be dealing with that
issue probably in the next video or in
the next lecture or whatever and what
does the religion of general relativity
say well it says that the ether is
really something they called space-time
in other words they say rather they say
right that the ether is simply this
concept called space plus time meaning
three dimensions of space meaning three
coordinates of space meaning three
number lines of subspace you need three
numbered lines to locate a point and at
what time did you locate it well at four
o'clock in the afternoon there's your
fourth dimension your fourth number line
they call these four number lines
space-time and to explain why the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system what
do they do they say the that's the
physical interpretation they sink the
Sun into the space time warp it and that
creates a wall especially a sort of
roulette wheel and the little ball just
goes around the roulette and that's the
earth and doesn't fly out of there why
because there's this wall of time warp
time and they could so what is that well
that's the ether it's just another word
for the ether or like who has it one of
these Nobel Prizes who said you know the
what they use in mathematical physics
today contemporary times right is the
ether but we don't call it that because
it's taboo yeah totally in agreement
that's what it is the ether is alive and
well it never died okay from the Greeks
to all the way to general relativity and
quantum mechanics and string theory all
of them have a different name for the
same thing at the Greek side which is
the ether what is the ether a bunch of
particles that's what the either that's
the definition of ether bunch of
particles a bunch of particles is not a
physical object any more than a bunch of
atoms is a table or a bunch of atoms is
a tree or a bunch of atoms is a rock you
can't define a rock by saying oh it's a
bunch of atoms
likewise you can't define the ether as
saying it's a bunch of particles so
anyone who does disagrees with the
definite my definition of the word ether
had better have a good definition be
definition and be ready to defend it
because uh I don't have any here oh here
it is because I'm gonna educate them
with what with my door roller okay so
make sure you you have a good definition
other than bunch of particles okay okay
never never stood that word be
pronounced in my presence
okay so you go to that site and what do
you find this guy says look he analyzes
the lunar Ranger lunar laser ranging
experiment that NASA did a few years ago
I think it was Apollo 15 to one one of
the ones that put what is it a
retroreflector on the moon they say they
put like ten or fifteen but only four of
them are functional or were functional
anyways one of them was from Apollo 15
and what they do they shine a laser from
the earth a very powerful laser right a
beam they shine it directly at the
retroreflector a mirror okay and that
would change it right back to the same
place where it came from which is this
tower that's got this beam right okay
and this is what this guy explains and
and so you have this laser hits the
mirror comes back and what they do with
that they measure the distance from the
moon to the earth that's what's called
late laser ranging they want to know if
the moon is getting closer to us or
farther away that sort of thing and and
by the way it's good because it measures
the speed of light I like that because
see it takes about 1.2 seconds for the
beam to go one way
that means round-trip you got maybe two
and a half seconds okay and the problem
here is that while the beam goes to the
moon and then comes back that's two and
a half seconds Ronnie golf okay
meanwhile the earth and the moon moved
around the solar system let alone the
Sun around the
Galaxy okay but we'll leave that out we
move around the solar system that's the
earth the moon does too but the moon
moves a little faster because the moon
moves at one kilometer per second around
the earth remember it goes around the
earth okay so here's the earth going
around the Sun 30 kilometers per second
and the moon going around the earth at
one kilometer per second okay you get
that so we got two motions here okay and
what's the problem well by the time you
hit the moon and it comes back you
should never never ever hit that mirror
the the source but it does and so the
issue is how do they do that do they
point the laser to where the moon is
going to be in 1.2 seconds which is the
time it takes for light to cover that
distance one way now they pointed
directly at the mirror and so and then
you know you got a factor in warp space
also there's warp space between the
earth and the moon so all these photons
are just falling down meaning this this
well this gravity well you know so they
can't be traveling straight at all
rectilinear nee right so we should
receive any photons back so this guy
says well I have an explanation he says
he says the earth and the moon moved
together and there's and there's only
and they're still within 7.5 kilometer
radius of the arriving laser light so he
says we're still gonna pick up some
light again he's thinking of one-way
mechanisms particles and waves
transverse waves and again that's the
nonsense of mathematical physics in in
genuine physics we put a rope there and
we tie the laser the the source right
directly to the retroreflector
one atom here is connected directly to
an atom here so you can't lose the moon
no matter where it goes in the universe
that one can go out to the other side of
the universe it's that that atom is tied
to
Adam here on earth no matter where you
are in the universe all atoms in the
universe are inter connected physically
interconnected by a an elongated
mediator which in this case is the
electromagnetic rope a DNA like Rho what
I like about what this guy said is
exactly that then he he gives the
example how the moon should work this
this laser ranging should work and this
I want you to listen to here it goes hey
what does he say well he says that
imagine the way to simulate this
visualize it how ether drag works with
lunar light is to imagine a string
between the retroreflector and the
telescope now how's that for for a
confirmation of the Rope hypothesis ok
so let's do it with a rope let's see if
if this guy is right ok
here we have it ok we have a string
there there's your rope ok yeah that's
how you simulate the light between the
laser and and in the retroreflector
and the detector back here on earth it
can never get low the moon can go
anywhere it wants that atom is always
connected to the atom in the laser see
how simple is and it always travels what
rectilinear Li why because that rope it
remains spot at all times all ropes are
always taught ok remember when we do
magnetism we do it with the thread not
with a rope some people confuse the
thread with a rope and the Rope with a
threat unless you get that right you you
haven't learned your ABCs yet and the
other one is that it travels quite fast
why because the fastest thing you can
imagine is a so-called torsion wave a
three-dimensional wave okay but it's a
torsion what we're seeing is a rope and
we're not seeing we can't touch it
either but what is there is a rope and
it's torquey and when you have torsion
like
rope here okay hopefully um II get this
now I'll leave it in there for a second
see we can all understand torsion and
you don't have to take my word for it
but go home tie a rope your
grandmother's clothesline whatever and
put two clothes pins at each end you
know one at each end well one the other
one moves instantaneously and you'll
verify for yourself how fast a torsion
wave is okay no physical object as a
wave it's known as a torsion what is
torquing is a physical object known as a
roll
let's see how they do it with particles
okay here we go with particles okay and
now the question is you know if the moon
moves
how do those particles reach the laser
the retroreflector the mirror and bounce
back to the source exactly like they
have to go back and forth along the same
axis why do we know this we know this
from the principle of ray reversibility
you put on anyone who studied a little
bit of optics will have heard of the
principle of reversibility light
retraces its exact path now how do you
do that if you do a Michelson Morley
type experiment where I the earth moves
around the Sun you know that light beam
should be moved to the side right now it
covers the same path because it's a rope
it retraces its path because light is a
torsion along the same rope to which it
went in fact the rope there is no one
way the Rope is a two way mechanism you
know here when you torque this you feel
it at both ends
simultaneously the rope is a
bi-directional mechanism that's the
fastest thing imaginable a torsion or
torsion wave how do you do it waves
transfers ways well here you say yet
okay now how's that for transfers way
one-way transfers ways by the time it
reaches the moon you
now it comes back well it's got to go
through warp space and that more move
the earth mode everything moved in the
universe but that wave always comes back
to to where it started
now isn't that magic yeah if you have no
explanation other than then particles
are waves and obviously you're gonna
have your rational explanations because
you cannot explain it with particles
with discrete entities and with one-way
entities which beside the point they're
slow I mean I want you to compare
anytime you want huh I'll race you you
just bring your stupid Oh transverse
wave which is the slowest thing
imaginable one dimensional longitudinal
waves beat the hell out of transverse
wave if you look at seismic waves that
create both of them the longitudinal
wave tribals 1.7 times faster than the
up-and-down transverse wave it better
because one has to go up and down the
other it's just moving along the axis
and when you take the torsion wave three
dimensional wave oh and leave them both
fighting the dust
nothing is faster than a torsion nothing
and not even jet no not any vehicle that
man has sent into outer space is as fast
as a torsion along a rope okay keep that
in mind that's gonna be my argument yeah
so anyone who wants to beat my torsion
yeah I'll bet you two million bucks
nothing is faster than torsion yeah okay
moving on here another comment
fellow says in case the Sun disappeared
the planets would continue in that sense
stable oh no absolutely not however when
the centrifugal force of the Sun
disappeared the movement of the earth
around the point in occupied would
gradually slow down gradually Mary oh my
yeah people have this notion that I
don't know where they got it
from mathematical physics that if you
make the Sun disappear
what did Brian Greene say it takes eight
minutes for the signal for you to find
out about it why because nothing can
travel at the speed of light or faster
right
maybe gravity he says travels at the
speed of light but it cannot travel
faster
well it's absolute nonsense and here is
trait it okay okay so anyone who who
wants to debate here you have it okay
okay so how long will it take for the
tightrope walker to fall I mean will it
take what until the rope there the cut
rope reaches his feet or do you think
he's got a few more seconds to go that's
more or less what these people are
saying okay they're saying that if we
cut all the whatever can keeps us bound
to the Sun it's got to take a long time
eight minutes for that information to
reach us because they talk about the
tribal of information now here is here's
the rational version okay and the
rational versions all atoms are
interconnected therefore the Sun swings
the earth around like a boy swinging a
ball around his head and if you cut that
string or let go of it
no son then that planet instantly goes
out flying out so there's no time delay
zero Tonya you could say you know as
soon as if the magician God whoever
makes the Sun disappear well then those
connections that we have to the Sun are
no longer connected to anything there is
no matter to which we are connected it's
known as gravity okay all those ropes
that connect us to every atom in the Sun
okay and here's another one moving on
another comment okay fellow says its
adhesion considered a form of gravity
and now there even though they're both
sticky it's not quite the same and here
let me illustrate that okay
give me a second I got so many of these
okay here's a breakdown adhesion okay at
the functions at the atomic level and
above actually at the molecular level
okay and here you see just a snapshot
they show that all these polymers that
they use for adhesives and so on well
they're made out of these chemicals and
the chemicals are attached in the
right-hand corner there on the right
hand side above you'll see a little red
circle and that's circling a hydrogen
bond okay so what they're saying is that
these molecules in this case right in
this specific case are sticking together
because these hydrogen bonds yeah
gravity is something else according to
the Rope MA model right
what we have is every atom is connected
to every atom in the universe therefore
for any two objects one object every
atom that comprises one object is
connected to every atom of the other
object the farther they are away these
ropes come together and they form a
single coaxial and the closer they are
you have this acceleration known as
gravitational acceleration which is
simply the new angles at which each rope
connecting their mutual atoms changes
there in other words they're no longer
aligned on the same axis and the closer
they are the more they fan out that's
the depth and that's the mechanism for
gravity very simple kindergarden stuff
typically some people have trouble with
that and usually those trouble are a
couple first they say I don't believe in
ropes we don't care
belief is for religion in science we
explain a mechanism so that you
understand it whether you believe that
there are ropes or not or or whatever it
doesn't enter the picture at all other
problems people say why can't I touch or
see the ropes
because Mother Nature made the mediator
of gravity and light and all in
magnetism so on invisible and intangible
that is not the
definition of the word object the word
object that we have in ordinary speech
is see touch we think that an object is
that which you can see and touch
everybody says well yeah I can see and
touch I can see it touch this rope so
that's an object no not in science
that's an ordinary speech and religion
in mathematical physics okay
in all these religions they use that
notion in science it's that which has
shape the rope has saved this rope has
shape and says does the electromagnetic
rope this rope the one we buy at a cart
hardware store is an analogy or simile
of the electromagnetic rope
why only because of its shape that's it
that's where the analogy stops all
properties tangibility visibility smell
ability here ability taste ability none
of those have anything to do with the
electromagnetic rope and that's the
first thing you gotta come to grips with
mother nature made the mediator of light
and gravity invisible and intangible
we're not gonna figure these things out
observing we can observe indirectly the
effects of these things but not the
thing itself not the mediator itself and
we're not gonna figure it out through an
experiment you know by touching or or
smelling or seeing none of that the the
light and gravity forever the meet
mediator of light and gravity
forever is denied the eyes in the hands
of humans that's why observation is not
a part of the scientific method that's
why experimentation is not a part of the
scientific method we're not going to
discover them mediators mother in nature
uses through see touch experiment
observation we're finished done don't
ever bring it up again I don't want to
hear the word observe or experiment ever
again okay
besides experiment is only to prove to
yourself ok so that you believe so that
you either change your opinion or
confirm your opinion that in opinions
and belief have nothing
do with science science is explanation
of a mechanism not what mathematical
physics says description which is the
only thing mathematics can do described
you know that's like saying you know you
go to the show you see the magician yeah
and he doesn't he does a little
experiment up there right he pulls
rabbits out of a hat and you ask the guy
next to you the math magician Ryan he's
you see how did you do what did he do
there how was that done and the guy says
well yeah I'll tell you what how he did
it
okay how he said well he opened the Hat
and he pulled 10 rabbits and he did it
in 10 seconds but yeah I mean I wanted
to know how he did the trick I want an
explanation of the mechanism and that's
the difference between science
explanations and the religion of
mathematics which is just describing
mathematically you take a ruler you take
a scale you take a a stopwatch and you
got through the field and you measure
and then you come back and say this is
what I measured accurately very accurate
I measured it with an atomic clock so
what so you measure and what can you
explain about the magic tricks that
Mother Nature does explain gravity and
I'm not I'm not talking about anything
out of this world I'm talking about here
we have a little ball I let it go and it
falls to the ground that's the only
experiment you ever needed for gravity
now I need an explanation I need to know
how mother nature does it what came in
physical contact with the skin of the
ball that's what I need
and anyone who shines up from that is
not doing science is doing religion if
you just say well it fell the 9.8 meters
per second square that's the
acceleration so what what have you
explained all you did was describe give
me a number that's all an equation what
is that for okay to do some technology
may be irrelevant to science science
rational explanations I need an
explanation of a mechanism that's what
people want to know people
don't want equations people want a an
explanation so don't keep us waiting ok
moving on here here's the in motion the
mechanism of gravity that I just
explained ok
here we have the elephant falling to
earth farther away he's got few ropes
attached to his he's got the same number
of ropes it's just that he's farther
away so the ropes come together when
he's far away as he falls to earth the
ropes fan out and that's the
acceleration of gravity right there now
you have a physical mechanism that
everybody can understand you can see why
the elephant is accelerated towards the
centre of the earth and why the earth is
round
sorry flat earthers I know that offends
you but yeah the earth is round and
that's explains why and if you have
trouble with what I just said here you
have authority okay let's give some
authority for those who believe in our
thirty we have Richard Miller a
professor at Berkeley
I think he's I'm not sure if he's still
teaching good so for example if you have
the earth there is a big mass here of
the earth with a Big M there and and you
have your little mass here every atom on
earth is pulling on every atom of you
pulling how does it pull you can you
pull with particles I mean I try to pull
with particles the other day I can throw
them out but I can't pull and I can't
pull with waves transference waves I
throw them out and the wave goes out
there you know the standing wave and I
can't pull anything with a wave because
there is no physical object called a
wave no no you gotta have a rope you
have a chain or something that connects
the object over there with the object
over here then you can understand the
first pull why every atom on earth is
pulling on every atom of you because
they're all connected by ropes
electromagnetic ropes why can't you see
your touch these ropes because mother
nature made them invisible intangible
and because that's not the definition of
an object an object is that which has
shape and not that which you can touch
or see and until you get those ABCs
that kindergarten stuff underneath your
skin you're not gonna understand
anything fishy from this site okay and
whether you believe me or now is
irrelevant we don't care about that your
beliefs in science okay
your beliefs have no bearing on
objective explanations of mechanisms
another issue brought up by one fo how
does the threat as a fundamental object
bend and twist okay and he had some good
issues here how can the threat
simultaneously be intangible to itself
okay and in case of ropes crossing and
tangible to itself in the case of thread
twining around itself to become a rope
good question
and we're aware of the problem we're
very much aware of that problem okay and
he says I was not able to find in your
book explanation for what keeps
ferromagnetic Nets out spinning in the
first place well let me address that
last question first and then now go back
to the first two okay and here it is in
the book we don't cover every subject I
mean this is an introduction okay so
here you have a little device called a
levitron and it's just floating around a
magnet and you know we explain what a
what the threads do the threads are
coming out of that magnet they're
invisible intangible loose they're
sweeping around and that's what keeps
that thing floating in the air because
you don't see you know it's magic
because only because you don't see the
threads if we could make the threads
visible you'd say oh that's stupid
that's so easy I should figure that out
I should have figured out how mother
nature does this magic trick right now
because you simply because you can't see
or touch what's in between there which
is the the threads from the
electromagnetic ropes that's why you
think this is magic
that's why because this violates
everything you thought about magnetism
okay but once you see the threads once
you visualize them then this is kids
playing okay and so we don't explain it
everything but you should be able to use
the thread theory the threads spinning
around to be able to even make a drawing
of this for yourself and
figure out how the threads do this so I
don't need to explain also every little
thing out there especially an
introductory book like the Rope
hypothesis which by the way is
downloadable free you just look at herb
in the description you can download it
anytime you want okay
it's from my site the Rope hypothesis
okay let me explain the other issues
that this fellow raised which are
important very important okay and here's
a my take on this okay so please pay
attention you're gonna have some new
material here we have two threads
crossing okay so you say see the thread
on the completely on your left there and
it's gonna cross together with one
coming down okay so we're gonna have
them cross each other and you can see
they blend at some point and then one
continues rolling across the other one
comes continues going down that's
crossing threads okay so they're both in
motion okay now he says why don't the
threads blend when they're following the
rope which is a good question and all I
can do is give you the best answer I've
got I can't tell you how very
comfortable with this answer myself
these are things that still need to be
debated okay these are things that need
to be resolved and all we can do is
pitch in ideas or figure out how mother
nature does this magic trick but my idea
is that if if you pull on the threads in
other words if the threads are pulled
out words they're squeezed like you know
one against the other
that's not the same thing as going
across each other so in one case there's
motion going across two threads the
other one is that they're simply
tightened down and let me give you a
little analogy just to reinforce that
take a bit of cotton a little strip of
cotton and you can pull on it and you
can see it disentangle and it breaks
apart right you can pull it pull it
apart okay I said I didn't have any
cotton to show you but I wish I had
today you can pull it apart right now
take that same
strip of cotton and twine it around
another piece of cotton okay so you
twined them around like a rope and now
pull on them you'll find that it's it's
much harder to pull them apart okay and
I think that it's something along those
lines this is just an analogy I'm just
trying to give you some ideas here I'm
not satisfied with them either I want
you to know that I'm saying that going
across or in any way right two ropes or
two threads they can go across but if
one thread ties around another one like
DNA and it's and they're tightly pulled
then they squeeze onto each other
they're not traveling against each other
they're squeezing against each other and
that's the best way I can think of this
happening under mother nature's world
right so yeah call me a liar whatever
but that's my best explanation to date
okay to that phenomenon okay the other
issue I want to mention here is that you
have magnetic repulsion and attraction
the threads in one case come down on
opposite side that's repulsion both
coming one coming clockwise the other
one counterclockwise
what's attraction one clockwise the
other one clockwise when one comes up
the other one comes down they interface
there and that's how they pull now why
is that the case okay so what I'm saying
is again you have if the if they go in
the same direction
okay let's understand the mechanism here
they go in the same direction when one
comes up right the other one comes down
okay and so there is an attraction so if
they're both going like that right let
me do it in the opposite direction okay
and okay so we go like that right and
now when one comes down the other ones
coming up because they're both going in
this case from your point of view
they're going counterclockwise right
okay so this one comes
this one comes up and there's your your
friction and that friction of many many
threads is like you know like this like
a paddle so you have you have paddles
you have gazillions of threads okay and
that's when it comes into the world of
touch okay please try to understand what
I'm trying to say I don't I don't care
if you believe me or you want to believe
me that's irrelevant
you need to understand what I'm
proposing what I'm proposing is that if
you have one thread coming down in the
other one coming up you know there's
gonna be a tiny friction if you have
gazillions of threads coming down and
gazillions of threads coming up
gazillions and gazillions ii would say
you're billions of billions then what
you have is that's where the attraction
comes in the closer two magnets are the
more threads that participate the faster
the attraction between north and south
okay I hope you understood the mechanism
here let me illustrate it get it here
give me a second here so I can pull it
up got so many of these like 40 okay and
there you see it okay on the left you
see attraction on the right you see
repulsion
okay so just look at it for a second you
can see what's happening to the threads
the threads on the upper part of a
magnet not in the north and south it's
perpendicular to north and south okay
these people will always seen it in the
wrong light it's up and bottom for both
magnets okay so I'm Magna is divided in
half not from north to south but from up
to bottom and what happens is the ones
on the top okay on the left hand side
you can see the threads are moving
clockwise and so indeed the same thing
goes for the second magnet it's right
next to it and so what happens to the
threads well you can see that they're
latching on to each other and the same
happens with the bottom part of the
magnet but in opposite direction
counterclockwise Mother Nature doesn't
understand north-south or east-west or
positive negative mother nature
understands physics she under
Stan's clockwise and counterclockwise
that's physics the rest is just mere
opinion okay what do we see on the
right-hand side well we see the two
magnets facing each other because we
turned one of them around and now you
can see that they're clashing both on
the bottom and on the top of the magnet
okay and the bottom pictures there those
are two wires there in the case of the
left the one on the Left there's two
wires coming in to your eyes if the
electricity is flowing into your eyes in
both of those wires they will attract
and that's the pattern that you will get
if you sprinkle iron filings over two
wires carrying current in the same
direction if they carry current in the
opposite direction as the one on the
right you'll see here in a minute you'll
get repulsion okay and that's the
pattern that you get when you sprinkle
what is it
iron filings over two wires carrying
current in opposite directions okay so
they match everything matches that's the
explanation for magnetic attraction
according to the Rope model of light and
gravity okay magnetic field is made out
of swinging threads okay there's
something in motion or as mr. James
Maxwell said there's matter in motion
and Faraday also said after studying
magnets for many years he said look
those lines of force they're physical
yeah and here we see why here we see a
magnet under water it's picking up iron
filings one at a time okay we have to do
it in slow motion underwater so that you
can see it you can see that yeah
obviously something is moving nearing
collecting one arm filing at a time and
you can't do that with particles you
can't do that with ways no what you got
is threads that are swinging around the
magnets okay then you can explain it
rationally whether you believe it or not
that's your personal business doesn't
concern us and more on the issues this
fella raised
how the rope which is intangible as a
rope and the thread which is intangible
as a thread suddenly becomes how it
creates tangibility and one way is here
the way we do it with the atom okay
that's the construction of the atom atom
is a and we're looking at the hydrogen
atom just to make it simple that's we
have enough with that okay we have all
these ropes converging on our atom and
they fork out at the electron shell okay
the one forms the electron shell the
other one forms the proton dandy-lion
not empty space like mr. Rutherford had
he had empty space between his ears now
there is no empty space inside an atom
but that's a long story and again it's
got to do with tangibility and the rope
you can't touch it and that's why he
confused empty space with tangibility
okay that's a long story anyway and I'm
gonna do that today but anyways you can
see how two atoms merge okay and so how
does the thread become three diamond in
other words acquire three-dimensional
properties such as touch well if you
take one thread or one rope it doesn't
you can't touch it or see it okay but
now if you take gazillions of them like
in the case of magnetism or in the case
of the electron shell now it's suddenly
acquires the property of touch now you
have that shell and that shell hits a
net against another shell and there's
only two possibilities in the case of
hydrogen gas which is the one I'm
depicting at the bottom there if both
atoms are rolling in the same direction
yeah either both going clockwise as they
approach each other the rope
disintegrates between them in other
words it you're eating away the links
until you have one surface of one atom
of one electron shell touching the other
one and it screws inside the other okay
and they form that figure-eight and
eventually you know the the oval which
is the hydrogen molecule two hydrogen h2
right and so now we can explain that and
if they go in opposite direction one
goes clockwise the other one
counterclockwise the rope takes them all
the way till they touch and then they
bounce away and the Rope reconstructs
itself with what where the same threads
coming out of the atoms okay do you
believe in it I don't care
the issue here is understanding we
science is about understanding
objectively explaining a mechanism not
about belief if you believe or not is no
concern to science it's your personal
religion okay and so here I just want to
show a little difference between the
religion of quantum mechanics based on
particles and the rope model okay here
you have different types of bonding okay
you have the covalent bond according to
quantum mechanics which is two hydrogen
atoms and they form this figure eight
for who knows what reason and why and
the issue there as always you know and
you can see it better than that ii
pictured ionic bond what are those
circles well those are orbitals right
and they're not orbitals their orbits
but one fellows will find out in a
minute
he called them orbitals yeah he thinks
that orbitals are who knows what you
know they he calls them you know the
energy levels they use all these
hocus-pocus words now it's an orbit and
they take all these orbits and they make
an orbital they take all these verbs all
these itineraries and they turned them
into an orbit up in an orbital what is
an orbital it's a valence band or a
energy level or they have all these
synonyms for it okay no they never use
that what they use at the bead when you
want to explain ion ionization or you
want to explain electricity you never
talk about orbitals what they taught you
or orbits for that matter all they talk
about is the electron bead it's the
electron bead that goes out of the atom
and the only issue that quantum
mechanics has to answer that has always
had to answer they never answered and
they never will is what keeps the
electron bound to the probe
to the nucleus especially is as if mr.
Rutherford says an amped an atom is
mostly empty space between the electron
bead and the proton then what is what is
keeping that electron bound physically
bound to the proton and please don't say
fields or energy or any idiot idiotic
word of mathematics I need a physical
object I need to know what keeps that
electron from flying out and I need a
physical object and don't put anything
in there because Rutherford it's gonna
get angry he's gonna say it's empty
space anyways metallic bond again you
can see the differences under the Rope
model the metallic bond is simply an
array of atoms which are swinging
they're all aligned they're swinging in
the same direction okay according to the
religion of mathematics what you have is
all these beads moving around in
different direction they don't know why
they don't know what keeps the beads
bound to the atoms which in this case
are a bunch of ions because they lost
their marbles so you know you figure it
out and the hydrogen bond which is a the
fourth type of bond you can see it's a
very tenuous bond like in the case of
water and the way we explain we say look
that bond that's that so-called hydrogen
bond that's that's the rope itself okay
and when when water freezes which means
that bond has such low s very long
wavelength
very low frequency okay remember C
equals wavelength times frequency right
and if you increase one you decrease the
other because the velocity of light is
always the same through any medium not
like quantum says that a denser medium
light goes slower no light is always the
same speed between any two atoms it
doesn't matter what material it's true
and I've covered that subject in detail
in the past anyways here you have the
hydrogen bond what is it it's just a
rope and if that rope is stretched you
know so that the wavelength in this case
we call the link length is very long and
it's got very low frequency well then
what you get
is ice and I've got a picture of that in
my book I'm not gonna cover that right
now but you can see the differences
between quantum mechanics and the Rope
model that we propose ours is a physical
mechanical model babies can understand
it because all you need to do is look at
the pretty pictures and understand it
you might have a couple questions okay
we answer them but if you don't
understand it that's what we're
concerned about you know what is it that
you don't understand yeah do you believe
in it we don't care yeah now you're not
talk to your priest on Sunday in Sunday
school and tell them what your beliefs
are yeah okay another question regarding
physics here comment or whatever okay
they're so far down now you gotta take
time to raise them okay about the three
objects and existence in your pictorial
representation there's one object object
one object oh and the black stuff that
is the third object in case of no black
stuff the two objects are in contact
touch situation in other words no
distance okay let's do it your way let's
let's let's do it
he says that we remove space and there
is no distance okay so here we have two
objects and they're separated by this
black stuff which we call space and what
is he proposing he says well what if we
remove space which is the third object
well space is not an object but let's
remove space okay pay close attention
here now okay I'm gonna remove space
okay here goes one two three
whoa what happened oh the D objects
disappeared well yeah I mean if you
remove space you have no backdrop to see
the objects forget about distance we
don't have objects you need a backdrop
for objects here is uh I'll show you
another example here here we have God
okay God in space do you believe in God
do you know that God exists do you know
that he doesn't exist
well let's remove space Oh God
disappeared
yeah God has no backdrop poor fellow
you make God disappear you you wipe them
out of existence without backdrop
without a contrast you have no objects
forget about distance so every time that
you get an object that's the reason the
word object is a concept because the
word object requires two - what is a
what is the concept a word that invokes
two objects for two words treated as
object in this case we're treating space
as an object but space is not an object
we treat it only for the purposes of a
relation the shape and the contrast any
questions okay so no you can't remove
space because you don't have objects
without space okay yeah you know having
a backdrop the day you remove space you
have a single object in the entire
universe no no you know you have the
block universe and an infinite block
universe because it's not an object
anymore you know you wiped out the
objects you have no objects because you
can't see its shape you need contrast so
don't remove space please when God was
born
hopefully space was there before he did
you know because God could not have
created what gave him shape okay let's
move on here give me a second here and
get my my bearings here okay one fella
wrote got so many of these Jesus is lots
of questions came in okay he says we
understand the word ether the two jus
just doesn't go down it must be even
forgotten in or prohibited in the
rational scientific use completely we
don't need the word ether for anything
it just confuses and we have no use for
it but then why doesn't the same happen
to words like porridge spin size etc etc
well some of those were most of those
words are irrelevant to science the
physics okay we don't need the word
point we don't need the word line we
don't need the work force we don't need
the word what is it
gravity really is all those concepts at
least you know you can talk about you
can introduce them in your your
discussion but the words you absolutely
need to define and here I'm gonna put
these up these are the foundations of
science okay you need these words for
physics you can't do physics without
them and by the way no one has ever
defined these words scientifically
especially in the religion of
mathematics mathematical physics physics
requires an object that's an
non-negotiable principle okay you can't
do physics without an object you remove
all objects from the universe you have
nothing to observe you you you there's
nothing happening okay and so you need
to define that word something which is
the opposite of nothing if something is
that which has shaped nothing is that
which doesn't okay so now we can use
them consistently because they're
antonyms and this is separation between
two objects and locations a set of
distances from there we can now build on
these other three words that you need
you need to know what a concept is and
distinguish it from something from an
object no one in mathematical physics
has any idea what the difference is
between a concept and an object we have
the word exist physics is the science of
existence you that's all that physics
does it tries to figure out what exists
okay so anyone using the word exist in
any way shape or form whether he knows
it or not has stepped the boundary over
into physics motion to more locations of
an object not that which changes
location as some people define it no
changes as other is a synonym of motion
so you can't use synonym that you find
motion you can't say change anywhere in
the word motion in the definition of the
word motion okay so those are the words
we need to do physics
moving on here again so many of these
questions and issues okay here's another
one okay to think geometry mathematics
is in a part of science physics is a
false belief okay guy wants mathematics
in there well all you got to do is
define science and science we define as
rational
explanations a very simple definition
very powerful and today no one has
defined science I showed the other day
I'm not gonna go through that again but
I showed the different definitions we
have a science today and people don't
have any idea what science is and so
because they don't have any idea the
mathematicians have turned over and you
know they they did whatever they wanted
to do and they said Oh Sciences
description and math is the language of
science and a physic and that's where we
have you know if this fight yeah to try
to bypass three bases of physics
experiment observation and experience is
presumptions okay let's do an experiment
let's do an observation okay
little stone little rock I let go of it
it falls to the table if the table
wasn't aired fall to the floor I'll do
it again rep repeatable experiment you
need to have make it repeatable for it
to be scientific right okay so we'll
repeat it there it is yay Don the floor
under tape okay we can do it a million
times the the stone falls on the table
we did the experiment we repeated we
made a repeatable experiment and we
observed now what is the cause of
gravity why does it fall to the floor
not to the ceiling so now with
experiment and observation we have not
done science all we did was gone you
know a lot of people do experiments they
don't understand anything of what they
did they just did I did an experiment
you know no you if you haven't drawn any
information any they caught it now this
if you can't explain it if you can't not
explain the magic you're not doing
science so this is nonsense experiment
and observation are not part of science
science is explanation that's the part
that's science the other stuff is for it
for Gophers so you want to do go forward
go go go for it
to make your own definition of words is
asinine they're not my definition of the
word there's scientific definition of
words and anyone is Willy who was a
skeptic who doesn't like them or
whatever whose religion is destroyed
losing my religion
is welcome to come in and challenge them
and propose alternatives we need to
define words for purposes of physics and
that's what I do
you don't like them it's very simple
just provide scientific definitions that
you can defend with sword and shield
right okay to think love is a concept is
psychopathic okay I'm a psychopath yeah
I love is a concept sorry to break the
news to you they think consciousness
resides in the brain while we have known
since the lifeit experiment it is a
non-local to the body is called ignorant
yeah it's people who believe that the
soul goes to heaven you know this kind
of stuff consciousness my mind went to
heaven yeah no when the brain dies
you're the brain produces thought
thought thighs with it you're you don't
dream anymore believe me you don't go to
heaven you you don't you go to the
ground and you get eaten by their worms
or whatever okay to make visible the
invisible is cognitive dissonance no no
see you have air and it's invisible and
so now I want to you know maybe a
professor at the University wants to
explain it to his students so what is he
gonna put on the board what is he gonna
put on the screen well he's got to put
molecules you got to put atoms and you
say well you're making the invisible
visible oh yeah because I'm trying to
pictorially show what air is and then I
can explain something because there is
something pictorial for you to grasp so
yeah you got to make the invisible
visible sorry you should go to college
and you'll kill all that ignorance
believe me the Rope is intangible and
visible you have to imagine it correct
perfect to think ropes would allow for
motion and rotational orbit without
becoming a spaghetti mess is ludicrous
no because they're intangible and
invisible so you don't have to worry
about tangibility and visibility okay so
that was quick yeah yeah okay here's
another fellow and this fellow says he's
got a lot of issues that he raised
I'm gonna go over them one by one
momentum is mathematically indicated by
that's momentum equals MB which is mass
times velocity but what is mass yeah
what is mass mass is defined by Newton
as resistance to change of motion is
that what mass is resistance mm-hmm I
don't know because other people say it's
the quantity of matter so which is it is
it resistance to change of motion which
is dynamic which is an experiment I
gotta push something or pull on it to
find out if it has mass is that how we
define it or is it the quantity of
matter which means that what I'm gonna
count atoms what is mass okay well as I
always say mass is weight no difference
people say how can you say that we
learned in high school that mass and
weight are two different things
well yeah but see we determine master
weight and if you take the kilogram the
famous French kilo to the North Pole it
has a different weight and how do we
know that because we weigh it if we ever
count atoms in the liquor and kill oh no
we never counted atoms so we just
weighed it so the mass is weight weight
is mass and you can't never know
mathematician has ever extirpated mass
from weight they they have this concept
and they say well mass is the quantity
of matter the measure resistance let's
say your weight is the measure of
resistance to so now that we and uh but
let me put this up here as well give me
a second here so that we talk
intelligently about mass okay and so
here are the answers to those to this
day no one has ever defined the word
mass so we don't have the word of
definition of the word mass mass is a
measure of resistance to change but also
quantity of matter so which is it
you know actually their Wikipedia so
seven different notions of mass and one
of those is relativistic maths and the
other one is inertia mass they have all
these masses and what's interesting is
that you know when an object moves
according to you relativistic mass its
mass increases so what do we mean by
that are we measuring the resistance are
we increasing the quantity of matter
okay so that's why it's important to
define these things and then this fellow
says mass is defined by Newton as
resistant to change in motion so maybe
for negative momentum negative momentum
transfer remember that you throw the
ball and it pulls things in because it
delivers negative force negative motion
so this guy's trying to save that he
says the resistance the change of motion
is decreased or is less resistive
important direction versus the other you
know it's easier to say that negative
momentum is total nonsense
poppycock how's that for a definition of
negative momentum okay you know it's
people are trying to salvage the
unsalvageable and that's to say that
you're because mathematical physics has
always used the particles whether wave
or particle has always been a particle
because the wave is waving of the
particles so it's always been particles
and for the first time we're saying look
we don't do things only through pressure
we're gonna do things through pull and
what's got to be pulling is a rope that
is between two and really the rope
doesn't pull but the point is you have
to have an elongated mediator between
two atoms only then can you explain
action at a distance and like mr. Muller
said you know every atom in the earth is
pulling on every atom of you every atom
maybe now how does it how do you do that
with particles you got to be a good
shooter you know you're throwing all
these marbles and you're hitting every
atom and somehow pulling them through
negative momentum yeah
poor God trying to manage that with his
computer you know and again if you don't
believe me then we go to Authority
everyone believed in our 30 okay so here
we have them we have mr. Taylor and mr.
wheeler and they say nature does not
offer us any concept as the amount of
matter history has struck down every
proposal to define such a term even if
we could count number of atoms or by any
other counting method try to evaluate
amount of matter that number would not
equal mass mass is not the quantity of
matter and mass is not the measure of
resistance okay we don't know what mass
is because no one has defined it that's
why they use it because it's an
undefined term and you can always say
hey you know we have a zero dimensional
singularity no volume no radius no
diameter but it's got infinite mass we
call it a black hole
yeah where's called an angel call it a
spirit probably a better word for it
okay uh this other fellow also raises
another issue he says the three-body
problem okay and he goes with us he says
let's even get it it visits in classical
mechanics the three-body problem is the
problem of taking the initial positions
and velocities of momenta okay of three
point masses and solving for their
subsequent motion according to Newton's
laws of motion blah blah blah okay
historically the first specific three
body problem to receive extended study
was the one involving the moon the earth
and the Sun okay let me tell you what
the problem especially relativists have
and they'll never solve it because they
just don't have the mental capacity the
gray matter needed to solve this problem
okay so so let's go with with what these
people proposed here's here's the
problem now let me put it side-by-side
here so you can see me right okay this
is the problem
yeah you take workspace the canvas
analogy or explanation or dissertation
or argument and with two bodies no
problem you can show how the earth goes
around the Sun or you can show how the
moon goes
around the earth what happens when you
put a three bodies in there you know
like you just said Sun Earth Moon okay
well you can do that with relativity if
you just take those three you say well
the Sun weighs the canvas downwards okay
no problem so the earth rolls around the
Sun around the equator of the Sun right
oh no problem
now the earth also weighs the canvas
downwards so the moon rolls around the
equator of the earth more or less right
okay no problem
we're okay there but what happens when
you go to two other systems inside the
solar system we go to Oberon and that's
one of the moons that orbits your anus
and what happens you're the Sun weighs
the canvas downwards Uranus goes around
the equator of the Sun but not over on
Oberon goes according travels around
Uranus according to what according to
the direction in which Uranus spins
remember we're all interconnected right
and now we can explain that where is it
yeah all right here's the analogy okay
here's over on and my hand is gonna be
you're honest this is what's happening
and of course if you're gonna spins this
way okay you can see what's what's
happening there okay then it's gonna
spin against the Sun okay so this
confirms more of the rope model than
your warp canvas model okay and then
when you go to Sharon which is Pluto's
moon right and it turns out that Sharon
rotates towards the Sun okay in other
words and it's in the direction which
Ludo spins spin in other words the
satellites spin more or less in the
direction in which the planets spin and
that destroys relativity because all
these should be weighed weighing the
canvas in the same direction and the
moons should be going around the
equators they don't do so they they move
according to the spin of their primaries
okay and that is if anything evidence
for this
you know the fact that all out of all
the atoms of a moon are connected to all
the atoms of their respective planets
and in the direction in which that
planet spins that's more or less in the
direction in which their moon your
satellite spins that's in general terms
much better theory than the three-body
problem here which mathematics can never
resolve and never will okay because you
don't resolve this with numbers you
resolve it by proposing a mechanism
making the invisible visible okay okay
here we have again mass weighing down
space-time this is their version okay
two body problem no problem try to put a
third body in there and you got serious
problems because if the earth cannot
leave the depression because there's a
wall coming up with the skin of the
earth then how come the moon can go
right through that same you know the
moon grows around the earth how can the
moon go through that same wall that the
Sun puts behind the earth okay so so we
got a problem with space-time with the
analogy doesn't work the mechanism
doesn't work okay and here we see the
Rope version okay now you can see why
the earth doesn't leave the solar system
it's because it's pulled not because
there's a wall behind it like in general
relativity and the earth and the moon
also rolls around the earth and it's
tied to the Sun and the earth and so we
can now explain the epicycles which is
what mr. Ptolemy tried to explain you
know 2,000 years ago okay so yeah you
can think of as a cowboy rolling a lasso
over his head while his horse is running
around in circles that's essentially the
model okay do you understand it fine
we're done with science do you believe
it that's religion okay so we don't care
if you believe it or not
another comment lots of comments by this
gentleman hopefully I'll finish today
unfortunately many of the visits
throughout time have been rational this
coming up with theories with no evidence
like Bill Gates okay
good slap in the face let's find out
what the answer to that question is okay
here's my answer
okay evidence is what the prosecutor
uses to persuade convince convert and
recruit evidence has to do with what
religion evidence what you seek to
convince yourself so you look for
evidence to prove to yourself or to the
jury right evidence is in the eye of the
beholder evidence targets opinion and
belief not understanding not mechanisms
this God exists what is your evidence
okay and here you have the symmetrical
and beautiful petals of her rose and the
symbiotic relation a bee has within
evidence that God must exist because
only an unimaginably intelligent being
could make it as perfect as that or is
all evil that we see in the world a sign
that there is absolutely can't be an
intelligent being so what is your
evidence okay is that what evidence is
for for belief now we don't we clean our
noses with evidence in science we don't
use evidence we don't use experiments we
because experiments is only to collect
evidence right it's all evidence
evidence no in science we don't use
evidence have no purpose for evidence
evidence is for your personal belief if
you need evidence to come up with a
theory for yourself to imagine a theory
to visualize a theory a more power to
you when you come to the conference we
don't care about your evidence we care
about your explanation okay we got that
straight okay here's another comment
planetary motion of electrons is
incorrect okay I like that it is an
orbital not an orbit
what is it R what is an orbital bunch of
orbits that's what it is has different
shapes for different energy levels
energy level is that we don't recognize
the word energy at all it has nothing to
do with science only religious people
use the word energy and the word energy
is a different word for the word energy
that we had since days of old ok so
let's get some proof and evidence here
so that we convinced through evidence
and this is going to be an mp4 so I'm
gonna turn it on and you're gonna see
the answer to that first question what
is an orbit Tull okay let's find out
okay give me a second here
here goes I'll keep my mouth shut
go imagine that we take a picture of
this electron every second for a day a
week or month
you see that all these pictures laid on
top of one another
begin to form an electron cloud around
the nucleus remember all these
hypothetical pictures or data points
represent where the electron has been
over time
imagine that okay so what is an orbital
a bunch of orbits you just collect them
in over a month okay and builds this
cocoon which they later dismiss and say
we forget about the orbit oh we're gonna
do everything with the electron bead
that's how we're gonna do attachment to
another molecule do or to another atom
okay okay here's another one just so
that you get it's the same thing it
gives you an idea of what an orbital is
okay so that anyone who doesn't know
well you'll find out right now give me a
second here keep my mouth shut your yos
a negative ion is an atom or molecule
that has gained one or more extra
negatively charged electrons
a sodium atom has one valence electron a
chlorine atom has seven valence
electrons if the atoms collide with
sufficient energy the chlorine atom will
remove the electron from the sodium well
did you figure out what an orbital is
what does that be when the atom releases
that single electron right the sodium
releases the chlorine is there an
orbital still around the sodium atom or
is the orbital there only when the atom
has to fall from energy levels to create
light as mr. Bohr said I mean what's the
point of the orbit what is this orbital
is it a channel through to which an
electron beam moves is it like the
Broglie said you know that it's what is
it it's got all these fixed number of
links or wavelengths all around I mean
what is an orbital is there a physical
object we can bring out here and call
this as an orbital so so they've created
this orbital from orbits they took a
bunch of orbits a bunch of verbs and
convert it into a noun that's what the
math magicians did and everybody just
says oh okay oh well and that's what
people learn by rote instead of
challenging the nonsense you got a
challenge this this nonsense that comes
in to college and high school classrooms
okay no such thing as an orbital that's
garbage invented by math magician x'
that have no idea what physics is what
they did with numbers and they did
calculations and measurements and then
they turn that into a physical
interpretation which is ridiculous okay
here's another comment from you get it
up here yeah there it is okay and says
far2 concrete bound yes that's what
physics is about physics is about
physical because otherwise you're doing
ab stresses you're not doing physics
you're doing extra cyst okay
abstract is the opposite of physics and
like mr. Bourne said Max Born said in
the 60s and one of his books he said
physics is becoming more abstract yeah
it's going in the opposite direction
we're not giving physical interpretation
we're not giving rational explanations
for mechanisms what we're doing just you
know just what is it dumb
we're throwing around we're juggling
we're juggling concepts Oh energy and
there goes force you know yeah I dismiss
it completely
physics is physical so first rule the
first golden principle of physics is you
can't do physics without an object so we
need to define what an object is and yes
we do not do it with abstract concept we
don't do it with field with energy with
mass that garbage has no place in
physics okay
that's mathematics that's physical
interpretations of mathematics that's
fine if you want to put a number in an
equation don't bring that nonsense into
physics has nothing to do with physics
okay and here's another comment bunch of
comments by this fellow
okay here's uh so some things can only
be described in higher-level concepts
and mathematical relationships yeah
again we don't describe what the
mathematician did on on stage we need to
explain how he did the magic trick
and so described is what mathematicians
did because mathematics can only
describe that's how physics and science
became mathematical and mathematics
speaking the language of science in
physics why because that's all that
mathematics can do and that's this guild
just developed it it or two or hijacked
it in that direction now I want to know
a mechanism I want to know why the ball
falls to the floor what causes it I want
to know the physical mechanism contact
with the skin
of the ball that's what I need to see
and for that all I need to do is
visualize make the invisible visible and
we're done it's kindergarten after that
kindergarten stuff after that okay all
you need to do is understand the
mechanism and once you discover that
everything has to be connected that
rules out the particle hypothesis of
mathematical physics so-called physics
yeah so yeah the answer to that is there
it is what the science do science is not
described science explains math is what
describes therefore mathematicians have
defined science as a collection of
descriptions that's not what science is
and all explanations of mathematical
physics are there for and because of
that are irrational
what is it rational very simple we have
a definition for that we have to define
that word as well irrational means that
you're moving concepts you're moving
love around you're putting conscience a
lot of people like to move conscience
around they think it's a separate entity
you know you move the conscience around
the dream I moved my dream yeah good
luck with that one okay here's another
one again it has to do with lack of
definitions this individual does not
define terms scientifically probably
never learned how to do that nope no
mathematical physics has ever done so
yeah I don't know if he is a
mathematical physicist or not but if he
is well that would explain a lot
but anyone who is not a mathematical
physics also using words of ordinary
speech that's what they bring into
science and hear the term electron is a
higher level concept an electron is a
concept huh I thought it was a bead is
it a bead or a concept is it a thing or
is it an abstract concept which is a
relation between two objects which is it
and it has to be an induced but it is
also a real entity it's also an object
so this person's God is both a concept
and an object when he prays well he he
prays - what - the concept to the - God
intelligence
is that what he prays to does
intelligence have ears to listen to his
prayer and it's also an object yes that
guy with a magic wand who made the
universe right so so you pray the Botes
you cover all the bases God is both an
object and a concept then you're safe
you know because now someone challenges
you on the concepts I just don't know if
God's an object so comes to you against
your object notion said no gods of
concepts he's an intelligence so you
always win you never lose and that's and
he's turned his electron into the only
two possibilities every word in the
dictionary is either a concept or an
object object that which has shaped
concept for all practical purposes that
which doesn't very simple so those
electron have shape or not if it doesn't
it's a concept it doesn't belong in
physics you can't say that you move the
electron around and if it's an object
well then it's not a concept it can only
be one or the other you can't have yes
and no it's yes or no sorry okay it's
either on or off black or white okay
granted that you cannot reify a concept
which is what he just did but he is this
missing higher-level concepts as not
having anything to do with reality
yeah concepts are not with reality and
the way we do that in Sciences we define
what a concept is and what reality is we
define these words so we can use him
consistently and not like he just used
them he's got it rational irrational
definitions okay
go the principal physics requires an
object and you can't do physics without
an object what is an object it's that
which has shape so the electron either
has to have shape or it doesn't it can't
have both not have shape and have shape
at the same time okay but it turns out
that you know according to quantum
mechanics and here you have the
breakdown let me give myself back in
here okay
quantum mechanics treats an electron as
a physical object it talks about this
bead that moves they call it a point
particle whatever but they treat it as a
physical object because they say this
thing moves there's an orbit
it has location it could be here or
there so what are they talking about
hopefully it's not a concept they're
talking about an object okay so that's
why we need to define the word object
and the word concept and here you have
it okay
typical misconception of people who
don't define the key terms in their
arguments that's what this guy did they
casually introduced the vague notions
object concepts exist or under other
words reality real that's the center
name of exists so they say they talk
about reality but they don't know what
the word reality means so we have to
define these words to make sure that we
make mincemeat out of these people in
physics exist physical presence it's a
synonym of real and reality physical
presence it's a physical object presents
location straightforward it's gotta have
location if God wants to exist he first
got to be an object he's got to be
physical he's got to be an entity he's
got to be a medium he's got to be
something and then that's not enough
because you know if God is only in my
mind then he doesn't have location no
there's got to be distance between God
and me for him to have location then God
exists he exists why because I believed
no he exists because he has location
he's an object of location because
there's distance between his chest and
mind no atheists ever figure that out
atheists and theists argue tons of hours
in circles because they never define
these words they don't know what the
word exists means not one of them and
when you confront an atheist and tell
them what a the word exists means oh he
goes nuts he goes bonkers
because you're saying hey you're a
religious fool just like the theists in
the agnostic they're all fools
because they never define the word
exists okay so now you can see how
rational science is a little different
than the nonsense you see out there and
between atheists which is the religion
of mathematics hey and all these other
people okay physics that physical that
which a shape presents location
straightforward what is a concept
concept is a word that in books or
bodies to objects or two words that are
treated as objects for example the word
shape
together with a word space space is not
an object will we treat it as an object
to defined a word up
so object is a concept yes the word
object and electron is not a concept a
relation between objects kill'em treats
the electron as a bead so no electron is
not a concept for that you need to
define what a concept is you need to
define what an object is and define your
definition you got to get in the ring
and fight it out I'll be glad to spar so
if you want to want to get criticism of
your definition say you came to the
right place okay agreed the men of that
mass feel gravity and the like are not
physical entities well good and that
they eventually have to be explained
with better physics no no one's gonna
explain with better physics because no
one's working on that there's no money
invested in that no one's working on
better physics no one everybody
considers these words done deals already
in mathematical physics in fact they
don't use them they don't care and they
can use the words of ordinary speech and
they get by with that because they can
tell you whatever not so you can say
angels push the earth around the Sun and
people are gonna believe it is you what
do you mean angel yeah we proved it
mathematically see here's equation okay
you know if they say so and who knows
that all that mathematics out there
nobody cares about that people just want
an explanation well how the earth goes
around the Sun and the guy says angels
where do you believe that it's angels
because all mathematicians voted for
that theory
okay okay moving on here maybe I'll
finish today yeah here's here's an
another issue this fella raised uh says
he himself has not come up with the
answer with his electromagnetic ropes
cheap shot you know he I've got a
mechanism for every invisible phenomenon
I've got an explanation for gravity
mechanism right I got a mechanism for
magnetism electricity I've got a
mechanism for light workings of the atom
I've got an explanation of a mechanism a
physical mechanism for each one of those
so this is a cheap shot
no justification just words that he you
know because his religion is destroyed
so this is again a lot of people just
get offended and all that he can do is
just say oh but he didn't explain it
either well if I ain't praying what's
the book about I mean did you read it
did you watch any other mechanisms that
I put out there before you open your
mouth he's wrong about pull it has been
with physics at least since Copernicus
and Newton oh is that so okay Newton
states that he could not determine the
cause of gravity then onwards this pull
in fact good old Newton this beam borane
Newton he did it with particles he was a
particle man how do you pull with
particles please explain negative
momentum is then how you do it
you throw particles and just magically
the the course comes towards you in
science we have to use a rope we can
pull on the horse with a rope but I
don't know how you can pull on a horse
by throwing tennis balls at it or rocks
please show me the mechanism irrational
mechanism with particles or one-way
waves I don't think that if we don't
know the mechanism the basic cause
behind gravity or atomic theory that it
necessarily invalidates the theory and
what was the point of the theory theory
is an explanation and so yes if you
don't know then you don't have a theory
you don't have an explanation you don't
have a mechanism that means this
straightforward okay Jesus my God with
some of these people okay more to it I
like this one guy says the following
I think he's a guy says quantization
does not retain the older concept
classical mechanics I guess of the hard
particle it's an abstract particle not
not a physical point yeah you know what
I mean
agreed but that by itself does not
invalidate the theory yeah in science it
does in physics if you don't use objects
you don't put something with shape
it's not a hard particle there's then it
ain't a particle hey what are you gonna
put a point particle zero then mention
all zero diameter particle is that is
that how you do physics are you gonna
put a concept there are you gonna put
energy in in that little bundle of a
bundle of energy or are you gonna put
virtual particles I love those the you
know they come in out of the void and
whatever the mathematician is throw with
them using them in the equation the
particle goes back and becomes nothing
no it's not magic they say it's it's
science
yeah okay one more comment here okay put
it on top of this guy yeah what's the
comment here in a second here I'm gonna
organize these things to exist as an
axiomatic concept people really just
people never want to define the word
exists because it destroys their
religion you rape their virgins
yeah so they don't like that says and
needs no definition oh so your God
exists but we don't know what that word
exists means okay I see you have to
define it ostensibly by pointing to
things that you observe okay let's find
out what the answer to that is here's
the answer to that okay take this you
can take this to the bank okay so here
we go set like a turtle is just
individual who wishes to regard and be
regarded as rational and scientific if
exist means implies suggests insinuates
that it is point to things you observe
okay there's energy exist can you point
to energy does energy is the space
exists the field exists this magnetism
exists there's gravity is this God
exists does love exist please point to
any of these that you observed what ever
you observed
okay so it's very simple it's just point
if you got a point and that's the way
you got to define exists all you have to
do is point okay and so what is the
rational definition well here we have it
if God wants to exist he's got to have
two conditions once he's got to be an
object he can't be a concept and rules
out all concepts and he's got to have
location there's got to be distance
between God in my chest okay or my legs
or my eyes or whatever and there you
have the definitions of object and
location set of distances yeah so yeah
you get it do you find the word exists
if you want to officially want to do
physics physics is the science of
existence physics only deals with that
which exists you got to figure out what
exists out there in the invisible world
of mother nature you got to figure out
her mediators that's what physics was
all about not mathematics not gibberish
not equations none of that has anything
to do with with physics physics is tell
me how this universe works and then
we're done and it's not gonna take
another million years partly because
we're due for extinction very soon you
know as you know okay
last comment and here it is uh what
surrounds each particle we don't know
and yet and Goethe does not have an
answer either see then these guys make
cheap shots has obviously hasn't looked
at any of my stuff so here let me prove
that yes we do have an answer to that
question yeah okay and let me get this
other one as well get it close by here
it is okay let me show this one first
okay here's a single thread this is what
we propose there's only a single thread
floating out there this single thread
turns into all atoms and the ropes which
interconnect any two atoms so there's a
single thread it's a closed loop read
you can't break it you can't rip it okay
it can go through itself because it
doesn't have the properties of our
everyday
the world and again it has shape which
is the only property that the REIT is
required to for it to qualify as an
object okay and what is the backdrop
well that black stuff is space what is
space nothing
what is nothing that which doesn't have
shape that which doesn't have shape
that's what space is
in other words space is nothing
absolutely nothing and what we see or
what we feel every day is anything above
atoms okay so atoms turning to molecules
we can see we can touch molecules at
different levels we can touch chairs and
you know higher objects you could call
them but we can't touch the Rope we
can't see the rope and we can't touch
the thread and can't see the thread okay
now let's go to the definition let me
get myself back in here and here it is
yeah cheap shot quantum claims that
empty space surrounds a particle a sea
of virtual particles that's what quantum
says so yeah quantum does have an answer
but it's an irrational answer because
they have no definition of what space is
because if as the religion of quantum
mechanics says a virtual particle comes
in momentarily and then goes back and
forms space in other words it
annihilates with its counterpart matter
with antimatter to form space
well that means space is made of
particles and if space is made of
particles what you get an answer is what
surrounds each one of those space
particles very simple and if space is a
physical object as mathematics holds
both quantum and general relativity and
string theory for that matter all I need
to know is that the shape of space just
draw it draw space for me okay don't
tell me it's infinite because there is
no such thing as an infinite object ok
rope hypothesis there are no particles
getting very simple it's a threat and
space is what serves as the backdrop to
the thread and nothing is that which has
no shape very simple very
straightforward all comprehensive all
understandable by a ten-year-old do you
believe it in we don't
care that's your personal business and
with that I'll see you next time looks
the other way